I have anal beads that are con  communicating with stockfish via  Bluetooth yeah we will get to that yes  we will get to that uh it's epic it's  actually scary how many people think  that's a real thing by the way which is  the danger of the internet but we yeah  we will get into that but I tend to  believe that people believing a thing  that's hilarious  at scale will make that thing a reality  I'm with Elon on this I think people  manifest the meme the meme becomes real  so that but that that's I in all walks  of life I think there is something about  humor  sort of uh being a  why doesn't why did I I was gonna well  was I I was going to say is I feel like  humor becomes a lubricant for the  trajectory of human civilization and I  don't know why the word lubricant went  into my head which means I understand  yeah but it's very Freudian